ça pour tourner n'a suivi ce cours c'est
une forme assez pour que je joue je mens
c'est pourquoi il faut mettre les
informations fidèles nos combattants ont
besoin de notre soutien ils ont besoin
du soutien de notre population
notre armée nos forces armées et puis
elles sont puissantes or nous avons la
population puissante ainsi nous devons
soutenir nos combattants
maintenant les combats sont en cours
dans le dos ne passe à l'est à dans le
sud dans le nord
nous
avons combattu les ennemis en ont essuyé
de lourdes pertes
nous avons eu des attaques ont été
attaqués à l'est au nord au sud la
solidarité et la clé aujourd'hui pour
préserver l'état ukrainien
cela dit
nous avons des armes pour nous protéger
pour protéger nos terres et nous sommes
prêts à
livrer des armes à tous ceux qui se
portent volontaires pour protéger nos
terres
notre peuple ukrainien et tous ceux qui
ont de l'expérience de combat militaire
s'il vous plaît rendez vous
dans des endroits et des centres prévus
à cet effet pour pouvoir se mobiliser
s'il vous plaît suivez bien les
informations détaillées le ce matin nous
avons des blessés
blessés dans des hôpitaux
votre aide est essentielle vous pouvez
donner du sens pour les sauver
maintenant nous menons un travail
approfondi en terme de défense et nous
avons besoin dans ce type de nos
entreprises notre avenir ir en dépend
travaillons ensemble pour notre avenir
pour que nous ayons tous les produits
nécessaires la banque nationale et le
système bancaire de l'ukraine ont tous
le potentiel nécessaire pour pouvoir
soutenir
nos intérêts les intérêts des citoyens
ukrainiens je suis reconnaissant à tous
les hommes et toutes les femmes
politiques ukrainiens qui ont soutenu
notre indépendance notre pays nous
n'avons aucune opposition maintenant
nous sommes tous concitoyens d'un beau
pays et nous nous battons pour la
liberté de notre pays
soyez prêts pour défendre vos classes
vos villes je tiens à vous dire que
la décision du conseil national de
défense et de sécurité
se tient tous ceux qui sont prêts à se
mobiliser pour notre payer ce matin
chers concitoyens
ce matin est historique
cela dit cette histoire est différente
aux différentes pour le cren et pour la
russie
nous avons rompu les relations
diplomatiques avec la russie l'ukraine
ne cédera pas sa liberté quoi qu'il en
dise et quoi qu'ils en pensent ceux qui
sont à moscou
c'est la liberté c'est une autre
aux valeurs suprêmes la fédération de
russie a attaqué nous a attaqués ce
matin
comment l allemagne 1 données des nazis
qui on a attaqué lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale la fédération de russie
est sur le chemin du mal
et
beaucoup de pans de la population russe
les citoyens russes vont devoir faire un
choix aujourd'hui
sur quel chemin avancé
il est l'heure de descendre dans la rue
et de dire
stop à cette guerre à la guerre avec
l'ukraine 1
et je tiens à m'adresser aux citoyens
ukrainiens et
un russe au citoyen russophone
je sais que cette information
ne sera pas retransmise sur des
chaînes télé parce que ce sera
bloqué mais vous savez que l'histoire ne
pourra jamais être bloqué chers
concitoyens
ukrainien
tout ce qui est ou des membres de
familles des membres proches de famille
en russie chers journalistes je vous en
prie
communiquer avec eux transmettez leur la
vérité c'est très important merci
beaucoup nous allons vous tenir informé
toutes les heures en profondeur nous
allons parler à notre population à notre
peuple à notre société est maintenant
c'est l'armée entière notre pays de
plusieurs milliers et millions de gens
gloire à l'ukraine